before we get criticism we have to undo
our jackets because we're sitting down
because someone got really angry last
year i just wanted to show off the suit
let's do it let's do a drip appreciation
real quick yeah unlike last year i
actually am wearing a jojo suit oh joe
you actually wore pants this time i wore
pants this time
no one will ever know i didn't wear
pants last time from the jordan suit
with a with a black shirt this time
mixing it up feeling spicy all right
wait i i'm because i've never worn a
double breasted suit normally do you
still unbutton it or it's appropriate to
button your double-breasted swivel yeah
yeah i thought i thought i guess so
connor and i would just
do it i'll keep i'll keep it back all
right all right whatever whatever
i went with the mr thai this time change
it's nice nice good looking good let's
try the champagne there yeah
i guess yeah ourselves off and yeah
for the next two isn't that just a
regular trash day
that's no different from what we
normally do but uh ladies and gentlemen
this is episode 100 yes we've hit the
big three digits 102
years of trash taste
102 years i haven't had this much head
since i went to a jojo meetup
oh my god this is like back at the
walmart it isn't a [ __ ] beer
if we were truly cultured we'd be
drinking our champagne glasses i will
say that this is nice we don't have
trash taste champagne glasses
um we're just drinking out normal wine
glasses by the way wendy thank you for
the glasses thank you very much for the
glasses well cheers boys boys to 100
episodes 100 episodes
[Applause]
wow we are
literally in triple digit episodes my
god that's scary that's gone so quickly
fine joe do you know what i forgot about
i forgot that we moved to a new studio
this year
yeah
this year huh happened this year
was it the last episode yeah last year
yeah and we only had like four or five
episodes after the trash chase awards
before the move yeah that's right it
wasn't long after wasn't it yeah yeah
but it didn't feel that way because the
last episode we filmed in the studio old
studio was the trash taste awards right
i believe so i probably
it's kind of now it's canon now that
that is it
no one can confirm
i think because we tried to delay it as
much as possible to have the awards as
close to episode 50 as possible even
though we'd already secured our new
studio and we needed to record a bunch
in uh uh we've got a bunch of episodes
to
uh make sure that we had enough episodes
to cover us for the move so yeah the
trash days episode was the last episode
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah how did you boys feel about uh i
have you ever been on the podcast that
made it past like 50 episodes
no i've never been on anything that made
it have you ever been on a podcast
before my own podcast that lasted two
episodes i had i had my own radio show
that lasted
the
anime show yeah i think i did like 30
episodes of that how many episodes of
portal
did that and you got like 20 or 14
something no i don't know it was it was
waiting i was more than 20. it was way
more your old self yeah yeah yeah you
don't get another chance to start again
you're the only one who can defeat me
exactly right exactly how many how many
episodes you probably got to like
maybe like little under 50. maybe
because the thing is there was like two
versions that was like poor taku and
jaetaku so it was it was like that went
on
yeah this is ghandlor that went on for
like four years though but it was four
years not as consistent as trash taste
so it is a very very different vibe i
think yes actually you have 76 videos i
don't know if that's 76. that's 76
episodes then we've we've already beaten
hey
[Music]
new pb new pb i mean to be honest it's a
miracle that like a podcast even lasts
over a hundred episodes true i feel like
i feel like i feel like over 50 episodes
like oh yeah honestly it's pretty
impressive that we have uploaded every
single week we've never missed a week
you've never missed an episode we've
never had to delay it a day please don't
let that be poorly you know you know you
know you know
it isn't i think it's impressive
you know you know what i will say
because like most most other podcasts
they go on for like an hour per episode
yeah we've done two hour episodes bar
like i think two or something yeah 400
episodes that's two that's like roughly
200 hours of talking yeah too long yeah
too long too long at which point do we
make as much content hours as one piece
that's that's that's the next goal that
is the next goal i want i wanted to get
to the point where there will be people
out there who will go what takes longer
to finish one piece
i mean we're getting there
yeah but like think about it a lot of a
lot has we've done a lot this year uh
because we've obviously moved studio uh
and i think trash tastes after dark has
just been like a massive thing that oh
yeah
i mean i remember last year we had like
three streams or something that we would
stream because we kind of felt like it i
think we did
four or five episodes of trash today
but then obviously there weren't so much
like you know like like a twitch show as
more just like uh you know a trash taste
after birth you know type of thing or
like oh after
you know
after after you know
just like squeezing that last little bit
from like the main episode into like a
stream you know i think it's really cool
we have like a different set for the
live streams and the [ __ ] the the normal
podcast you know yeah and you know it
offers a different kind of trash taste
experience
yeah was just the same one yeah because
because like i think the issue with the
old trash taste streams is that it was
just more trash taste it just looked
like trash yeah it was it looked like
trash daisy which we did the same things
as we do on trash taste we just talked
uh just with a live chat but i feel like
there's definitely
uh
we've definitely been able to distinct
uh make trash taste after like more
distinctive not only with the set but
with what we do on it as well because we
have we get to do like play some fun
games
uh we get to do some fun stuff
could you ever imagine trying to do the
24 hour stream in the old office oh my
god that would have sucked off for sure
ashley would quit like yeah you told us
you know it's good because uh people are
starting to comment oh well i like trash
taste after dark more than trash taste
now so that means that we're doing a
good job yeah yeah yeah that's like
that's like weirdly flattering yeah it
is yeah to be like oh we beat ourselves
i mean like if you prefer trash taste
off dog that's like all good that's
still trash taste baby
yeah
what is the trash taste awards resource
music right
to people who don't know what the trash
taste awards are it's something that
we've done once before and we liked it
so much that we're doing it again yeah
basically we're gonna try and do it
annually yeah basically you know there's
a lot of moments in trash taste and not
everyone can keep up with there's a lot
of uh a lot of content a lot of
arguments a lot of dumb [ __ ] that
happens maybe a screenshot you recognize
you're like where would you episode that
from yeah so basically this is an award
show to kind of have you the viewers
vote on your favorite moments of the
last 50 episodes of trash taste yeah
most i guess iconic moments the dumbest
screenshots the baddest takes and uh
when we complain about america yeah so
it's basically just a highlight reel uh
for you guys because there's a lot of
trash taste content now not only on one
channel on multiple channels so this is
basically inside joke the episode yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it's it's it's your
it's your chance to catch up to all of
the weird and wonderful moments you may
have missed over the years
yeah so if there's like a moment you
know you see during the trash taste
awards where you're like oh i want to
know what that's like you know in
context i want to see the full scope of
it then you can go back and check it out
and catch up on it and uh for us we just
get it to suck our own dicks that's uh
jojo that's that's why we're wearing the
jojo suits right that is why we're
wearing the jokers yes yes we are yes we
are don't deny it you don't deny it this
is literally like the obama image with
just like the medal right now
oh look look at all these awards sure we
have a bunch of categories we tell
everyone what the categories are yeah
just go through them all yeah do you
have a slide for that ashley or no no
i think we i do oh really i do have a
slideshow
brilliance ashley
actually planned ahead for us
by the way it's spelled award you that's
an inside joke again i got to explain
that because oh yeah yeah yeah the last
time i did the post calling for ideas
for the awards i did a title i read it
yeah i did a typo so that's why it has a
w it's not that funny but it kind of
stuck around it's also because we're
giving ourselves a w yeah i guess we are
award wasn't enough i needed another dog
joey if there's one thing trashcase is
not about it's not about getting w's
joey because none of us get w's it's
like two w's cancel each other yeah it's
all else and so we're about to find out
on this award man i'm gonna go to the
first slide what's going on with all the
nominations right yeah yeah yeah so uh
we have hot take of the year that's
number one we're just going out of the
gate we're going straight on
you guys are in for a treat we're best
out of context clip the screen grab of
the year most degenerate moment most
salty moment
monkey moment named after me i suppose
yes uh the best story the biggest clown
the biggest chad the best nickname the
best complaining about america moment of
course yes sorry americans sorry best
meme the fans they actually talked about
anime
that's a new one right that is a new one
best engine best drip laziest drip best
rent best argument worst food take best
poop moment i think that's new yeah yeah
that's the most privileged moment that's
new that's new yeah i made it the [ __ ]
up award yeah yeah yeah
which is nice
best chess taste after dark episode
which is oh yeah yeah yeah this quiz
answer which is new as well moment of
the year and the best trash taste
episode of the year according to you
guys yeah so you guys voted on this and
you guys gave us the nominations as well
so we might judge your taste yeah
so if you want to blame anyone you can
blame yourself so if we get to a certain
point you're like no no the best one was
definitely not in these nominations yeah
that's on you yeah so i mean i mean like
i wouldn't blame you guys because
there's a lot of content that happened
this past year and even like we were
making the content and we don't remember
hardly anything uh happened this year
it's gonna be like a nice trip down like
memory lane right because i guarantee
there's gonna be a bunch of moments like
oh that got nominated yeah i i do
remember i do remember looking at the
nominations list and there was like one
moment that i remember happened that i
think deserves to be represented
somewhere here so i'm gonna just gonna
shout it out now yeah uh because it was
actually at the old studio which is why
i think it got like past overview
but it was the moment where the
confusion happened when conor was
talking about taking the fridge all from
my house yeah from your house and like i
that was the only moment i remember post
i was like oh damn if only i remembered
early i could have actually put it in
but like uh mood and you can play the
clip because i just want to give it a
quick shout out because it's one of my
favorites of the year finally getting
rid of my uh
my laundry machine
uh washing machine yeah we're getting
rid of ourselves yeah i got rid of my my
cockroach infested one
oh you still have that one
yeah she'll have that okay
yeah yeah it is nice to get rid of it
and get a new one get something nice you
can afford it
i'm taking the old one from this studio
are you
amounts of confusion where connor says a
story about taking the fridge and we all
think all three of us thought three
different things i thought the right
thing it's my story
because i phrased it in a way that was
like what the [ __ ] because because it
was like using like
using the scripts like that and it and
we were like saying oh you took it from
this place and yeah yeah and it was just
like the perfect like chaotic moment and
i remember like i remember like one of
my favorite pros was like the subreddit
breaking down how this yeah yeah and it
was like
it was like a jcs
criminal cycle okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and fails between yeah
unfortunately unfortunately uh it seems
many people forgot that because it was
actually at this point
so
you know you'll notice there's like
recency bias with some of these yeah we
don't know who's won yet we are totally
in the dark but we know the nominations
obviously
um so yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see what people chose yeah
yeah i mean i'm excited for it